à toutes et à tous donc je vais
rapidement vous adresser quelques mots
d'abord pour vous remercier les uns et
les autres que vous soyez présent
physiquement dans cette salle de la
conférence de presse du Sénat ou que
vous soyez présent via une vision à
distance pour que nous puissions vous
donner le rendu des conclusions de la
commission d'enquête sur l'efficacité
des politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique il m'appartient
de vous rappeler avant que je ne cède la
parole aux rapporteur Guillaume Gontard
que cette commission d'enquête a été
formée mi-janvier à la demande du groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire dans le
cadre de son droit de tirage au Sénat et
au Sénat chaque année chaque groupe
politique à la possibilité de demander
l'examen une question particulière la
direction de l'instance est alors
partagée entre la majorité et
l'opposition
ce qui explique aujourd'hui que je suis
j'ai été donc que la présidente de cette
commission d'enquête et que le groupe
qui a demandé donc la commission
d'enquête à travers Guillaume gantard
qui en est le rapporteur alors depuis
cette date puisque la commission
d'enquête a été formée à la fin du mois
de janvier nous avons tenu 21 séances
plénières nous avons réalisé trois
déplacements en Isère dans les
Alpes-Maritimes et à Bruxelles auprès
des institutions européennes nous aurons
auditionné pendant ces cinq mois de
création de la commission d'enquête 174
personnes que ce soit en audition
individuelle ou à travers un certain
nombre de tables rondes soit un très
large panel du secteur et du spectre de
la rénovation énergétique des logements
parce que je le rappelle bien notre
commission d'enquête a voulu se centrer
uniquement sur donc la rénovation
énergique du logement bien sûr que le
spectre pouvait être beaucoup plus large
à travers ne serait-ce que les bâtiments
publics mais nous avons voulu donc
concentrer tous nos travaux sur la
rénovation énergétique des logements
nous aurons donc siéger pendant plus de
66 heures nous avons également demandé
une éthique de législation comparée et
au final notre rapport fait un peu plus
de 200 pages et il formule environ une
vingtaine de propositions que le
rapporteur va vous présenter dans
quelques instants ce que nous avons
voulu faire c'est d'abord nous avons
voulu comprendre véritablement pourquoi
notre pays ne parvenait pas depuis de
très nombreuses années à atteindre les
objectifs qu'il s'était fixés en matière
de rénovation énergétique des logements
et puis d'autre part nous avons cherché
à véritablement imaginer des solutions à
formuler un certain nombre de
propositions et ces propositions nous
avons voulu plutôt que de retenir de
nouveaux à la fois des objectifs qui
pouvaient encore être être plus vertueux
que ceux qui ont été fixés à travers
l'atteinte de la stratégie nationale bas
carbone en 2050 des objectifs qui
auraient été encore des objectifs plutôt
déclaratoires voire incantatoire que
véritablement réaliste nous avons
cherché dans les propositions et dans
les solutions à donner des réponses qui
soient des réponses pragmatiques
réalistes au plus près des territoires
et à l'écoute de ces territoires mais
aussi à l'écoute des professionnels des
collectivités locales et territoriales
et bien sûr de nos concitoyens que nous
souhaitons voir embarquer encore plus
dans ce parcours de rénovation
énergétique de leur logement nous
pensons que ce n'est plus maintenant le
moment de nouveau de fixer des objectifs
ni même de remettre en cause ceux qui
ont été mis dans le cadre de la loi
climat et résilience et qu'il n'est pas
non plus besoin de justifier aujourd'hui
le besoin impératif de rénovation
énergétique des logements mais nous
sommes pour nous convaincus qu'il nous
faut maintenant passer
et dans la mise en oeuvre de cette
politique de rénovation énergétique des
logements c'est en tout cas l'une des
forces de notre travail et l'un des
grands défis de la politique que nous
avons souhaité relever en la matière en
nous appuyant je le répète encore une
fois sur les acteurs de terrain en
déployant une véritable chaîne de
confiance et en développant une filière
industrielle française qui permettent de
réussir justement l'accélération du
rythme des rénovations et principalement
des rénovations globales performantes
puisque aujourd'hui ces rénovations
globales performantes elles ne sont pas
loin de là à la hauteur de ce qu'elle
devrait être mais donc c'est aussi le
bien fondé d'un certain nombre de
propositions pour que nous puissions
embarquer le plus grand nombre dans ce
type de rénovation et passer de la
massification des rénovations par gestes
à des rénovations qui soient efficaces
qui s'inscrivent dans un parcours qui
soit quand même pas trop long et qui
conduisent véritablement à des
rénovations globales performantes parce
que c'est à ce prix là que nous pourrons
essayer d'atteindre les objectifs que
nous sommes fixés soit d'ici 2030 soit
un peu plus loin d'ici 2050 voilà ce que
je souhaitais vous dire en préambule de
cette ouverture cette conférence de
presse et je laisse sans plus tarder la
parole à notre rapporteur Guillaume
Cantard
merci merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues qui sont qui sont présents et
qui nous ont également accompagné pour
ces pour ces travaux merci à vous tous
pour votre présence et puis également à
ceux qui sont du coup qui nous qui nous
regardent en visio
je crois que madame la Présidente a bien
introduit en tout cas le sujet peut-être
effectivement revenir sur pourquoi
effectivement le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires est décidé de
mettre en place cette commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique
c'était à la fois de se dire
que quand on regarde ce qui se passe
déjà sur l'ambition qu'on peut avoir et
puis sur peut-être replacer la place du
bâtiment et de la rénovation énergétique
le bâtiment c'est 48% de la consommation
consommation d'énergie donc on voit que
c'est un gros un gros bloc en tout cas
quand on veut travailler tracer cette
route sur la neutralité carbone et c'est
28% des gaz à effet de serre et donc on
voit que c'est en tout cas un des
secteurs sur lequel il faut agir sur
lequel on peut agir et sur lequel on
peut agir je dirais de manière massive
pour faire baisser cette réduction des
gaz à effet de serre et de se mettre
justement dans cette orientation de
cette prévision d'une neutralité carbone
à 2050
et donc il nous a paru important je
dirais même primordial de se dire voilà
on a une politique publique qui qui est
mise en place qui fonctionne en tout cas
avec avec certaines mesures depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années les de Paris avec
des accords toujours avec des objectifs
toujours très ambitieux ça a été rappelé
les accords de Paris c'était d'atteindre
500 000 logements rénovés type BBC par
an et on voit bien qu'on est très très
loin du compte et que ces objectifs on
les a augmenté année après année on est
passé à 700000 700 000 logements cet
objectif de 700 000 logements rénovés
mais on voit que le résultat
qu'on a pu mettre en oeuvre n'est pas
tout à fait à la hauteur que si on
regarde suivant les différentes enquêtes
on doit être aller entre sur les
dernières années entre 20 à 50000
logements qui ont été rénovés type BBC
donc il y avait déjà de se poser les
questions à la fois sur on a des
objectifs ambitieux on a et ça a été
rappelé aussi un consensus politique ce
qui est pas fréquent on va dire
dans différents domaines mais là je
dirais que politiquement on est tous
d'accord pour dire que oui il faut agir
je l'ai rappelé avec avec les chiffres
sur l'importance de de l'action sur les
gaz à effet de serre et tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire il faut avancer
très fortement sur ces politiques de
rénovation thermique donc à consensus
positif mine de rien de l'argent public
on peut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'argent public qui ont été mis pour
cette pour cette politique de rénovation
énergétique alors on peut toujours
discuter du plus et d'ailleurs on aura
des propositions effectivement sur cette
question énergétique mais en tout cas on
a eu au cours des 10 dernières années de
l'argent qui a été mis sur cette
politique et donc c'est se poser
réellement la question justement de
l'efficacité de cette des politiques qui
sont mises en place et de l'argent
public et utilisé pour arriver justement
à atteindre ses objectifs
et puis ben c'est vrai que malgré ce
consensus malgré cette ambition on voit
bien et je l'ai dit qu'il y avait des
résultats qui étaient peus un peu peu
satisfaisant et
j'ai un peu l'impression un petit peu
comme si on était au d'une montagne que
la montagne elle était assez importante
à gravir
mais qu'on n'avait pas encore trouvé le
bon chemin et qu'on était un petit peu
dans des sentiers au bas de la montagne
qu'on essayait de trouver une direction
que parfois on se perdait parfois on
revenait en revenait en arrière
mais du coup un manque un manque de
clarté et qu'on est encore en recherche
justement du chemin pour arriver
justement en haut de cette montagne donc
on a un cap on sait où faut aller on
sait justement où est le où est le
sommet maintenant il faut trouver il
faut trouver le bon chemin moi qui suis
plutôt un montagnard c'est voilà on a
des des cairns c'est des des petits
signaux qu'on met le long du chemin et
ben c'est c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
et par à travers les propositions que je
vous que je vous présenterai c'est voilà
tracer ce cap là étape après étape sur
comment on peut atteindre ces objectifs
pour arriver justement au sommet de au
sommet de la montagne
donc c'est évidemment vraiment le but de
ce rapport c'est à la fois un bilan et
je pense qu'on a un bilan très complet
sur ces politiques publiques et puis de
tracer cette itinéraire qui soit assez
clair ça a été rappelé c'est un travail
collectif
transpartisans puisque l'ensemble des
des représentations politiques sont dans
cette commission d'enquête c'est un
rapport qui a été voté à l'unanimité
donc mais c'est vrai que je voudrais
assister sur le fait que c'est vraiment
un travail collectif avec l'ensemble des
des collègues ici au Sénat qui ont
participé à ce travail je vais pas
redire les chiffres que madame la
Présidente a pu dire mais c'est vrai
qu'on a siéger 66 heures qu'on a
auditionné plus de
74 personnes donc c'est un travail
particulièrement important mais qui nous
a permis d'avoir je dirais dans un
premier temps déjà une photographie
assez exacte de à la fois là où on est
comment ces politiques sont mises en
place et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
évidemment modifier
le premier le premier constat c'est
d'abord une politique qui est en
chantier je l'ai dit on voit qu'on a des
tentatives on a des choses qui sont en
train de se mettre en place on a des
choses qui se structurent on commence à
voir justement ce chemin qui se trace
mais c'est encore en chantier on a
encore 5,2 millions de passoires de
passoire thermique
5,5,6 ménages qui sont en précarité
énergétique on voit le nombre et
l'impact que ça peut avoir sur
l'ensemble des Françaises et des
Français et il y a un chiffre peut-être
important enfin sur ce sur ce rapport en
fait entre où est utilisé l'argent
public
notamment sur le bouclier énergétique
sur la dernière année ce bouclier
énergétique qui permet de
de deux on va dire de permettre de
tempérer en tout cas le coût de la
hausse de l'énergie qu'on a pu connaître
ces derniers temps et donc cet argent
public a été mis à disposition des
particuliers des collectivités des
entreprises pour faire baisser pour
atténuer leur facture leur facture
énergétique ce coût du bouclier
énergétique c'est 64 milliards d'euros
sur la dernière année un petit peu enfin
un peu plus d'un an c'est des sommes qui
sont colossales et donc on voit bien que
cet argent là il a servi juste à essayer
de faire en sorte qu'on passe le cap en
tout cas qu'on puisse encore permettre
de se de se chauffer à des tarifs qui
puissent être encore acceptables mais
surtout cet argent public on le sait
aussi bah servi à financer en fait la
spéculation autour du marché de
l'électricité
mais face à ça si on regarde l'ensemble
des aides à la rénovation qui ont été
mis sur le même temps et donc ils
permettent justement de faire baisser
ses dépenses ses dépenses énergétiques
on a mis si on met tout à bout
l'ensemble de des politiques qui ont été
mis en place que ça soit ma prime rénov
que ça soit prêt à taux zéro que ça soit
les C2 et cetera quand on additionne
tout ça on a mis vite 8,6 milliards
d'euros ce qui n'est pas rien mais on
voit le décalage qui peut y avoir entre
d'un côté 64 milliards d'euros qui ont
été mis pour je dirais atténuer l'effet
de la hausse de l'énergie et puis ce
qu'on a pu mettre en terme d'argent
public pour au contraire aller vers la
sobriété faire en sorte justement que
les ménages subissent moins justement
cette cette précarité énergétique
donc on voit que voilà ce décalage qu'on
peut aussi avoir dans la mise en place
de ces politiques publiques mais je l'ai
dit je l'ai dit aussi ce n'est pas
qu'une question financière une question
d'argent on y reviendra ce qu'on a pu
voir en tout cas dans ce premier constat
et dans cette politique qui est en
chantier c'est peut-être ce risque de
découragement et ça c'est peut-être un
point un point important sur le fait que
on entend un petit peu parfois de se
dire bon les politiques la rénovation
thermique c'est très sympathique ça
coûte très cher mais en fait on
n'atteint pas nos objectifs donc en fait
c'est pas très c'est pas très viable
c'est pas très performant
et ça c'est vrai que c'est un discours
qu'on peut qu'on peut entendre
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas une réalité
mais en tout cas on pourrait avoir cette
tendance et on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans
les politiques dans des politiques
publiques qui ont été mises en place
aussi récemment et dans ces annonces du
gouvernement c'est d'aller uniquement
vers une décarbonation et c'est donc
d'aller vers changement de chaudière et
de se dire bah en gros il y a quelque
chose d'assez simple si on passe tous
nos équipements de production de chaleur
en fait en
chauffage électrique bah oui on
décarbonne et on va avoir quelque chose
d'assez efficace pour décarboner
c'est vrai on va dire sur le papier mais
c'est un vrai danger puisque si on va
sur cette orientation là et qu'on passe
tout sur d'électrique on va avoir de
vrai et ça l'ensemble des acteurs qu'on
a pu auditionner nous l'ont dit et nous
ont mis en garde sur le fait que on
allait vers un vrai problématique de
fournitures d'électricité de capacité à
fournir cette électricité et donc là il
y avait un véritable un véritable risque
et donc on a besoin justement de
réfléchir autrement et évidemment
d'aller vers cette sobriété et donc
d'agir sur les deux niveaux à la fois
agir sur la baisse des émissions de gaz
à de gaz à effet de serre mais aussi sur
la sobriété parce que quand on agit sur
la rénovation la rénovation thermique on
agit son confort du bâtiment soit la
sobriété donc sur -2 consommation on
agit aussi sur la santé des personnes
qui vivent dans des passoires thermiques
on sait l'impact que ça peut avoir sur
la santé et donc on agit aussi sur cette
question de santé de prévention sur sur
de long terme donc cette question de la
rénovation thermique en fait elle est
beaucoup plus large que le simple biais
de la bicarbonation et donc de ce de ce
risque qu'on pourrait avoir à un moment
donné de se dire bon bah il y a une
solution assez simple peut-être un peu
moins coûteuse là on a été tous unanime
en tout cas sur la commission pour se
dire non il faut vraiment avoir cette
vision cette vision globale ce qu'on a
pu voir aussi c'est un changement
permanent des politiques des politiques
publiques au cours des différentes
années alors en fonction des différents
ministères en fonction des différents
ministres et des différentes
orientations mais aussi on le voit avec
ma prime rénove certains nous disaient
sur les orientations de ma prime rénov
parfois c'est des changements plus que
plusieurs changements par mois en termes
d'orientation et donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est particulièrement
dommageable en fait sur la la visibilité
en tout cas de ces politiques publiques
parce que ça amène à la fois de la
tantisme de la confusion ça amène un
effet aussi de Stop and Go puisque en
fait comme on change à chaque fois
certains
hésitent ou en tout cas ne se lancent
pas dans ces programmes de rénovation en
se disant je vais attendre il va y avoir
d'autres d'autres mesures et donc ce
changement permanent est aussi
dommageable
et puis sur les objectifs qu'on a pu
qu'on a pu regarder enfin tout ce qui
ont été mis en place si on regarde en
2021 2022 et si on regarde les chiffres
en tout cas du gouvernement et sur ma
prime rénov c'est vrai qu'on a eu 700
000 à peu près
prime rénov qui ont été déclenchés donc
on pourrait se dire oui on a atteint ces
objectifs on a atteint justement ces 700
000 rénovations sauf que si on regarde
de plus près l'ensemble de ces chiffres
et c'est 700 000 gestes on va dire de
rénovation bah justement ce ne sont que
des gestes et à 72%, c'est du changement
de chaudière et donc on est à
très faible niveau de rénovation globale
de rénovation performante et je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure ça doit être aller entre
20 et 50000 logements qui ont été
rénovés sur ces 700 000 gestes qui ont
été faits en termes de de rénovation
thermique et de lien avec ma prime rénov
donc on voit que ça c'est une vraie
problématique en tout cas et c'est
vraiment un axe et un enjeu sur lequel
il faut qu'on puisse puisse travailler
et puis il y a aussi sur ces politiques
publiques un vrai problème de confiance
on a cette nécessité de redonner de
redonner confiance à toutes ces
personnes qui souhaitent justement aller
s'engager dans ce processus de
rénovation thermique et évidemment le
sujet des fraudes dont on a beaucoup
parlé dont on a beaucoup entendu parler
qui sont une réalité la question des
fraudes alors qu'ils sont à différents à
différents niveaux et sur différents
différents aspects à la fois sur des
réalisations de travaux qui ne sont pas
satisfaisants et qui ne portent pas
satisfaction à la fin mais aussi sur
l'accompagnement c'est-à-dire des gens
qui peuvent se faire abuser sur le type
de rénovation qu'il doit faire à qui on
va proposer une chaudière alors que ça
serait absolument pas ce qu'il devrait
faire en premier lieu il y a tous ces
aspects de fraude et donc on a besoin
aussi de retrouver cette confiance de
mieux encadrer et de mieux encadrer ce
parcours de rénovation
le
le les enjeux les enjeux majeurs qu'on
peut qu'on peut voir en tout cas sur
cette sur cette question de la
rénovation thermique c'est peut-être sur
la question du je dirais du défi de
l'accélération de la rénovation
je l'ai dit un petit peu un petit peu au
début si on veut atteindre cette
neutralité c'est 370000 logements en
rénovation globale qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait réaliser jusqu'à 2030 et
ensuite c'est 700 000 au-delà donc on
voit le cap qui a passé par rapport au
50000 que j'ai pu que j'ai pu annoncer
donc il y a vraiment un défi d'accélérer
cette rénovation et donc c'est les
propositions qu'on fait en s'appuyant
justement sur ce qui existe ce qui a dit
madame la Présidente le but de la
commission absolument pas été de
renverser la table au contraire c'était
de dire allons vers des des choses et
des propositions qui soient à la fois
réalistes réalise financièrement
réaliste pour pour la filière mais
réaliste aussi pour atteindre ses
objectifs indispensables et donc on a ce
défi de l'accélération de la rénovation
et je dirais qu'il y a quatre principes
qui sont ressortis c'est à la fois on a
besoin de visibilité
on a besoin de simplicité on a besoin
d'efficacité et on a besoin de Constance
cette question de Constance elle est
particulièrement importante dans cette
politique publique ça va avec aussi
cette cette visibilité et donc je l'ai
dit c'est à la fois redonner conscience
favoriser une rénovation à la fois et
fiscale efficace intégré dans des
parcours c'est intégré aussi cette
rénovation dans un cadre social et
solidaire pour permettre au plus faible
au plus défavorisé qui sont en plus
grand nombre justement à habiter dans
des passoires thermiques de pouvoir
accéder justement à cette rénovation
thermique avec un reste à charge qui
soit le plus bas possible qui soit au
minimum et avec un accompagnement lié à
des prêts à taux zéro etc pour que
l'impact sur leur porte-monnaie soit le
plus faible et qui puisse s'engager dans
ces dans ces travaux et puis la
stabilité avec un programme budgétaire
qui paraît indispensable sur sur
plusieurs sur plusieurs années donc la
Commission a fait 23 propositions je
dirais blog de proposition parce que
c'est pas
je vais pas les détailler complètement
parce qu'on en aurait pour un certain
temps et puis vous avez eu l'ensemble
des documents et puis je serai on met
tout à fait tout à fait prêt évidemment
à répondre à l'ensemble à l'ensemble des
questions mais c'est plutôt des blocs de
proposition sur des orientations on a un
premier un premier axe qui est plutôt
fixé justement une stratégie à la fois
stable ambitieuse et solidaire et il y a
un premier un premier un premier aspect
dans nos recommandations qui est sur le
mix énergétique qui doit être à la fois
équilibré et résilient en appui beaucoup
là-dessus parce que je l'ai dit si on va
sur une toute électrique on voit les
problématiques qu'on peut avoir et qu'on
a cette orientation et cette et cette et
ce risque là et qu'on a et que notamment
on a des alertes sur la réduction du
sur l'interdiction plutôt des des
chaudières à gaz notamment dont on dit
attention la nécessité d'aller doucement
de ne pas interdire en tout cas
immédiatement les chaudières à gaz
de ne pas forcément les subventionner
mais en tout cas de les garder dans ce
mix énergétique parce que on peut en
avoir besoin on peut en avoir besoin en
lien avec les pompes à chaleur on peut
en avoir besoin en lien avec la
méthanisation donc on a besoin de
l'ensemble de ce mix énergétique comme
on a besoin des réseaux de chaleur et
donc ne pas se lancer uniquement sur du
tout électrique et d'avoir vraiment
cette cette vision sur la sur la
production de d'énergie et sur l'énergie
qu'on va utiliser aussi avec ce regard
qui peut être local
on a besoin aussi d'avoir des
rénovations je les dis plus efficaces et
qui s'intègre dans des parcours cours de
rénovation globale et qu'on est cet
accompagnement complet des personnes qui
se lancent pour que même si on a des
rénovations par gestes on ne n'interdit
pas on dit pas qu'il faut pas qu'il y
ait de rénovation par geste mais elle
doit s'intégrer dans une dans un
parcours de dans un parcours de
rénovation pour que l'ordre de ces
rénovations puisse se faire justement
dans un ordre dans un ordre efficace
on a aussi de garantir et je l'ai dit la
stabilité des aides et leur financement
à travers une loi de programmation ça ça
nous paraît indispensable et je pense
que c'est quelque chose je pense que
tous les ministres peut-être un mais
sinon tous à l'unanimité nous dit qu'on
a besoin de cette visibilité sur du long
terme justement pour éviter ce système
de Stop and Go et d'avoir une loi de une
loi de programmation d'avoir une
trajectoire financière sur sur plusieurs
années on a besoin aussi d'assurer un
pilotage de la rénovation énergétique au
niveau du Premier ministre pour avoir
cette cette visibilité et une cohérence
entre l'ensemble des différents
ministères qui sont en charge de la
rénovation donc ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui nous paraît important ensuite
on a besoin de retrouver la confiance
et il y a un aspect qui paraît qui
paraît important c'est la question du
DPE ce DPE c'est devenu un outil central
je dirais primordial dans la rénovation
dans la rénovation thermique il a
beaucoup fait parler de lui sur sa
première version les versions la version
actuelle mais n'empêche que c'est un
outil central sur lequel s'appuie
l'ensemble des politiques publiques à
l'échelle européenne et donc on sait
qu'on ne reviendra pas on ne reviendra
pas dessus et en plus on pense que c'est
un outil qui peut être particulièrement
intéressant et pour qu'il soit
intéressant il faut qu'il soit à la fois
beaucoup plus fiable beaucoup plus
robuste et on fait un certain nombre de
propositions pour intégrer dans ce DPE
un certain nombre de à la fois qu'il
soit justement plus cohérent qui rentre
en compte beaucoup plus de choses que ça
soit sur la question des matériaux
biosourcés que ça soit sur la question
des bêtes du bâti ancien et de pouvoir
intégrer cette notion de bâti ancien
dans les dans la question gestion des
DPE
d'avoir voilà ce DPE qui soit beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus robustes et qui
prennent en compte l'ensemble et donc on
demande à ce qu'on puisse avoir et on
fait des propositions pour qu'on puisse
renforcer ce DPE et puis de rendre ce
DPE obligatoire pour l'ensemble en fait
des aides à chaque fois qu'il y a une
demande d'aide de se dire il faut qu'il
y a un DPE ce qui n'est pas tout le
temps le cas quelqu'un qui va changer sa
actuellement sa chaudière va avoir des
subventions mais n'aura pas forcément
fait de DPE et on pense que ce passage
par le DPE permet à la fois de sécuriser
justement ce parcours puisque la
personne qui va avoir son DPE on va lui
donner une trajectoire sur les éléments
qu'elle devra faire déjà de savoir où
elle en est où elle doit aller et puis
ensuite la succession de de gestes
qu'elle devra qu'elle devra réaliser et
dans le bon ordre et donc c'est aussi un
élément qui permettra d'éviter ses
fraudes puisque on aura cette sécurité à
travers à travers le DPE et ça évitera
d'être de pouvoir être abusé par la
suite et donc cette place elle est
particulièrement importante on a aussi
la question de replacer les
collectivités locales au cœur ça c'est
quelque chose on est au Sénat évidemment
mais je pense que c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important on a des initiatives
on a eu des innovations au niveau local
sur des plateformes de rénovation sur
des agences locales de l'énergie qui
fonctionnent qui marchent des
accompagnements qui ont été mis en place
et on dit attention aussi au
gouvernement est-ce que ce qui est mis
en place ne vienne pas gommer ne
viennent pas remplacer ce qui existe sur
les territoires mais au contraire qui
viennent s'appuyer sur ce qui existe et
qui viennent les amplifier et notamment
d'avoir ces plateformes de rénovation
c'est c'est guichet unique qui soit
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
notamment avec au minimum un guichet
unique par par intercommunalité mais ça
peut être beaucoup plus pour avoir
justement cette cette orientation mais
en n'ayant pas une politique qui qui
oublie ce qui existe ce qui existe déjà
il y a la question de la compagnateur
Renov qui est un accompagnement
d'accompagnateur Renov qui est
effectivement un élément important
justement dans ce parcours et cet
accompagnement à condition qu'on puisse
alternerment à la fois de confiance et
donc la question de la compétence et de
sa neutralité donc on fait aussi un
certain nombre on a eu on n'a pas encore
le total visibilité sur ce que sera
réellement l'accompagnateur Renov
notamment aussi sur sa mission mais nous
en tout cas on propose de faire très
attention sur la question de la
confiance ça peut être aussi un agent
territorial mais en tout cas faire en
sorte que tout au long et que si on veut
que cet accompagnement fonctionne il
faut qu'il y ait cette confiance absolue
quand on fait appel à lui et puis il y a
toute la question j'en ai parlé sur
comment mieux lutter contre la fraude
d'abord on propose de redonner des
moyens humains à la DGCCRF puisque c'est
déjà voilà pour à la fois le le contrôle
c'est aussi pouvoir mieux croiser
l'ensemble des contrôles puisque ce
qu'on a vu entre les contrôles qui
peuvent être faits par la NAS sur les
deux œufs etc on puisse avoir un
croisement des fichiers puisse mieux
détecter ces contrôles d'alourdir un
certain nombre un certain nombre de
peine aussi puisqu'on voit qu'on a des
peines qui sont trop faibles et en tout
cas qui ne sont pas assez qui
n'empêchent pas en tout cas c'est
l'ensemble de ces fraudes et puis
sur la question de tout ce qui peut être
numérique puisqu'on voit qu'on a un gros
billet sur tous les sites internet de la
personne qui veut faire sa rénovation va
taper va taper que rénovation sur sur
Internet va aller directement sur des
sites et qui vont vendre directement
pompe à chaleur en général et donc
sortir en fait du réel parcours dans
lequel elle devrait aller et donc ce
qu'on propose c'est qui est une une
obligation d'avoir un lien et d'avoir un
renvoi vers la plateforme France rénov
qui elle réoriente correctement et qui
du coup proposent justement puisque
maintenant ce qu'on dans ce qu'on
propose le DPE sera obligatoire et donc
permettra justement cette à la fois
cette cette prise en charge et d'aller
vers le vers le bon parcours
ensuite on a tout un volet sur le
financement de la rénovation on l'a dit
il faut aller vers de la rénovation
globale il faut vraiment prioriser la
rénovation globale et également sur une
rénovation qui soit à la fois sociale et
solidaire donc ce qu'on propose c'est de
porter les crédits de ma prime rénov de
4,5 milliards de les porter à 4,5
milliards pardon et ce qui si les
augmentent de 1,6 milliards et de
tripler les aides pour les plus modestes
et c'est-à-dire dans une rénovation
globale de pouvoir avoir des aides qui a
jusqu'à 45000 euros
la moyenne d'une rénovation globale pour
un pour un logement c'est entre les 50
et 60 000 euros donc on propose de
porter ses aides jusqu'à 45000 euros il
faut savoir qu'actuellement le total de
ces aides au maximum est à 17500 euros
et puis d'associer notamment les coupes
et TZ de le de l'augmenter de le porter
de 50 à 70 000 euros aussi pour les
rénovations globales
[Musique]
dispositifs mais je vous laisserai poser
les questions peut-être un point sur la
question du collectif et notamment des
copropriétés
sur la question des copropriétés on sait
que c'est là où on peut massifier
les aides
mais c'est là aussi où on a le plus de
mal à la fois sur la prise de décision
donc on a un certain nombre de
propositions sur la prise des décisions
dans les copropriétés
pour faire en sorte que cette prise de
cession soit à la fois plus simple plus
facile sur aussi la question du
financement et des prêts aussi auprès
des copropriétés et puis un élément
important sur encore une fois la
question du DPE on propose de rendre le
DPE ADPE collectif pour les copropriétés
actuellement on a un DPE individuel ça
veut dire par logement ce qui pose un
certain nombre de problèmes puisque dans
un bâtiment global on peut avoir des
logements très différents le logement
qui est au dernier étage qui est mal
isolé en toiture etc va être par exemple
classé Angers les logements qui sont au
cœur du bâtiment eux vont être de
meilleurs de meilleurs qualités et donc
ça ça favorise pas le fait qu'on est une
décision solidaire en fait sur
l'ensemble du bâtiment et donc de rendre
opposable un DPE objectifs pour les
copropriétés qui permet justement
d'avoir cette cette vision globale cette
prise de décision plutôt solidaire sur
l'ensemble du bâtiment on garde
évidemment le DPE pour les logements
individuels mais qui seront plus
opposables mais qui permet quand même
pour le locataire de savoir la qualité
réelle de son de son logement et ça on
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui peut permettre de booster justement
ces rénovations thermiques sur sur les
copropriétés et puis un autre aspect
important c'est sur le collectif le
collectif social et sur les bailleurs
sociaux là on voit qu'on a un vrai
levier et une vraie possibilité de
pouvoir aller très vite et de pouvoir
intervenir très fortement sur la
rénovation thermique les bailleurs
sociaux s'affaires ils ont l'habitude
ils ont d'ailleurs un parc plutôt
souvent de meilleures de meilleure
qualité ils ont envie d'y aller ils nous
l'ont dit ils veulent tenir les
objectifs il leur manque une seule chose
c'est du financement c'est en gros de
l'argent pour pouvoir mettre en place
ces
de rénovation donc là on a un vrai
billet et donc on propose de porter de
redonner 1,5 milliards d'aide de l'État
au bailleur sociaux dès 2024 pour
justement booster très fortement ses
travaux sur sur le logement sur le
logement social qui permettra d'aller
relativement vite justement dans ces
dans ces rénovations et puis il y a tout
l'aspect pour terminer sur la
structuration de la filière industrielle
puisque ce qui est quand même important
aussi à souligner c'est que 1 euro qui
est mis dans la rénovation thermique il
est loin d'être perdu puisque il y a
toute l'action qui va être fait sur les
économies qu'on va faire sur l'énergie
mais il y a aussi tout ce que ça va
développer en termes économique à la
fois lié aux entreprises mises en place
de structure on sait qu'on va avoir
besoin de matériaux on va avoir besoin
de matériaux biosourcés et donc là il y
a toute une opportunité pour développer
une filière locale de de matériaux
d'entreprises de réalisation de
l'ensemble de ces de ces travaux et donc
on a besoin de former très fortement
l'ensemble de ces entreprises on propose
de former plus de 200 000 professionnels
d'ici 2030 et de mettre des dispositifs
en place pour pouvoir former ces
professionnels parce que sinon on dirait
qu'on y arrivera pas en fait et c'est
toute la et je dirais la cohérence qu'on
doit avoir si on mettait beaucoup plus
d'argent il faut encore avoir les
capacités sur le terrain en termes
d'entreprise de pouvoir réaliser
l'ensemble des travaux donc la nécessité
effectivement de monter en charge très
fortement sur la promotion
professionnelle
là le soutenir fortement je l'ai dit
aussi la relocalisation de la filière
française de de matériaux et
d'équipements on sait notamment que les
packs actuellement sont sont fabriqués
pour une très grande partie voir la
quasi majeure partie en Chine et donc on
a besoin de relocaliser et de réfléchir
justement à la manière de réaliser la
fabrication de ces de ces matériels sur
notre sur notre sol mais également sur
l'ensemble des matériaux biosourcés que
ce soit la filière chanvre la filière
Paï tous les matériaux qu'on peut
réaliser à l'échelle à l'échelle locale
également sur le développement de la
géothermie qui paraît aussi quelque
chose d'important et qui est souvent
oublié c'est écho avec les premières
mesures que je disais c'est de vraiment
se replacer dans un mixte dans un mix
énergétique et puis à la question du
fond chaleur qui est où on propose de
doubler ce fond chaleur et de le passer
à un milliard d'euros
qui se font chaleur qui permet de faire
des réseaux de chaleur et des réseaux de
froid également et qui est vraiment
quelque chose qui peut être
particulièrement particulièrement adapté
à la fois sur les baisses de les baisses
de consommation et l'efficacité
énergétique qu'on peut avoir notamment
sur le collectif et sur les copropriétés
et puis
ma collègue est là et qui a beaucoup
suivi sur la question de la rénovation
du bâti ancien et patrimonial on a aussi
fait un certain nombre de propositions
j'en ai parlé à travers les DPE mais pas
que sur comment on prend en compte le
bâti le bâti patrimonial qui est pas
forcément le bâti classé qui est tout le
bâti qui est avant 1948 des bâtiments
avec des matériaux notamment souvent que
ça soit du pisé que ce soit de la pierre
etc qui sont mal pris en compte à la
fois dans le DPE mais aussi sur lequel
on peut avoir des risques en termes de
rénovation de dégradation de rénovation
qui ne soit pas
adapté à ce à ce type de bâtiment et
donc là on fait un certain nombre de
propositions à la fois en termes de de
formation en termes d'alerte aussi via
le DPE pour alerter aussi les
propriétaires de ces bâtiments pour dire
attention ne faites pas n'importe quoi
il y a des solutions mais par contre il
faut que ces solutions soient adaptées
et ça ça nous aussi paraît intéressant
et puis pour terminer parce que c'est
quelque chose pour le coup d'actualité
sur la question du confort thermique
d'été où on fait un certain nombre de
propositions c'est vrai que sur le DPE
tel qu'il est fait actuellement c'est
quelque chose qui est totalement
totalement oublié
ou en tout cas qui est juste
partiellement partiellement abordé et on
a besoin d'avoir une vraie réflexion sur
la question du confort thermique d'été
donc on propose d'associer justement des
PE tout un volet sur le confort
thermique d'été et puis également dans
les aides ma prime rénov que soit
intégré un certain nombre de dispositifs
liés au confort thermique d'été
puisqu'on sait qu'il y a des choses
assez faciles la mise en place de voler
la mise en place de persienne de store
de peindre en blanc des toitures
d'immeubles c'est des choses qui coûtent
peu d'argent et qui ont des efficacités
très fortes en confort thermique en
terre confort thermique d'été et donc il
faut qu'elle puisse être au même titre
que les chaudières que l'isolation etc
prise en charge dans la dans le cadre de
ma prime de ma prime rénove on sait que
c'est un enjeu particulièrement
particulièrement important on sait qu'on
a des pics de chaleur qui vont parfois
dépasser les 50 degrés et c'est aussi
néfaste de ville dans un appartement on
a eu des mesures qui ont été faits sur
l'été dernier avec des appartements à
plus de 38 degrés et donc on voit bien
que c'est totalement totalement
invivable et donc on a vraiment
nécessité aussi d'avoir cette réflexion
globale quand on intervient sur de la
rénovation parce que sinon on risque
aussi de faire des bêtises et ce qui a
déjà été fait c'est des rénovations qui
soient tournées uniquement sur le
confort d'été sur le confort d'hiver et
puis en fait qui sont qui n'apportent
rien en tout cas en terme de confort de
confort d'été qui reste d'être un enjeu
aussi important et un enjeu aussi
énergétique puisque sinon bah c'est de
la climatisation et donc de la dépense
énergétique et donc de la dépense
électrique voilà
rapidement le balayage un petit peu de
l'ensemble de ces propositions même si
voilà c'est difficile de de
vous faire l'exhaustivité de tout ce
qu'on a pu proposer on a un rapport de
plus de 200 pages donc je vous laisserai
le le consulter mais je suis
nous sommes évidemment prêt à répondre à
l'ensemble à l'ensemble de vos questions
oui
bonjour Adrien Vicente pour l'Agence
France Presse j'ai deux questions la
première sur le chiffrage des
propositions proposition qui propose de
de dépenser davantage ce qui a un
chiffrage global
et ensuite est-ce que vous en avez parlé
avec l'exécutif on a eu récemment le CNR
logement qui a couché de mesure assez
décevantes donc qu'est-ce qui vous fait
penser que que cette fois ça sera ça
sera pris en compte et qu'il y aura de
l'écoute du côté de l'exécutif
c'est une bonne question mais non je
pense que la position dans lequel on
sait on s'est mis c'est justement à la
fois ça a été dit réaliste mais
pragmatisme et on n'est pas on n'est pas
passé à dire qu'il fallait à la fois
doublé triplés on n'est pas parti sur
des montants qui soient complètement
déconnecté
et et à chaque fois qu'il soit vraiment
lié et notamment enfin à la fois lié à
des demandes et à des analyses qu'on a
pu avoir à travers les différentes
auditions et notamment d'anciens
ministres et d'ancien ministre qui nous
ont quand on leur a posé directement la
question qui nous ont dit que voilà sur
certains secteurs oui il manquait
il manquait de l'argent et qu'il fallait
et qui avait cette nécessité là et donc
à chaque fois on a plutôt chiffré quand
on dit que il faut rajouter 1,6
milliards sur ma prime rénov bah tout
simplement en fait si on fait le calcul
si on veut vraiment favoriser la
rénovation globale si on veut l'accès
sur plutôt les foyers modestes ou très
modestes bah oui on voit que on propose
il faut qu'on augmente justement cette
prime pour ces foyers modestes et donc
ça génère effectivement de l'argent de
l'argent supplémentaire mais c'est aussi
la condition pour qu'on puisse tenir ses
objectifs et c'est bien le but c'est de
passer de 20 à 50000 logements en
rénovation globale à l'objectif de 350
et ensuite 700 000 donc on est plutôt
sur une trajectoire financière qui
paraît plutôt cohérente alors je sais
que les annonces effectivement pour le
coup oui il y a pas eu d'argent
supplémentaire donc dit qu'il en faudra
quand même de toute façon sur la
question du logement social et le fait
qu'on propose un virgule 5 milliards ça
ne vient pas de nulle part c'est des
demandes qui sont récurrentes et qui
correspondent réellement à quelque chose
et encore une fois qui permettront
d'avoir un impact très fort et très est
très direct donc voilà après c'est sûr
que il y a un choix politique à faire
mais c'est pour ça aussi qu'on le
propose et qu'on l'intègre dans une
trajectoire globale et ce qu'on dit
c'est de faire attention et c'est ce
qu'on a pu voir à travers différentes
auditions c'est attention à avoir un
montant très important une année et puis
l'année d'après on va avoir beaucoup
moins et puis du coup on va devoir
changer notre type de politique ou nos
orientations on doit intégrer en fait
l'ensemble de ces augmentations sur une
trajectoire financière sur une loi de
programmation pour avoir cette
visibilité là et cette cette constance
dont tout le monde appelle de ses vœux
juste rajouter par rapport à ce que
disait monsieur le rapporteur bien
évidemment c'est un coût si on veut
véritablement atteindre des objectifs et
surtout passer à des rénovations
globales performantes mais il y a aussi
en contrepartie des économies si j'ose
dire quand on va quand on veut renforcer
le contrôle des fraudes à travers plus
de sanctions alors des sanctions pénales
mais aussi des amendes qui soient
proportionnelles aux chiffres d'affaires
des entreprises c'est aussi ça génère
aussi des recettes si j'ose dire pour
pour l'État et puis il faut voir aussi
que tous ces travaux et cette politique
de rénovation énergétique dans les
territoires elle crée de l'emploi elle
permet aussi à un grand nombre
d'entreprises de pouvoir avoir plus de
marché plus d'interventions et donc
forcément plus de richesses qui
remontent dans dans l'économie de notre
pays après je laisserai peut-être le
rapporteur parce qu'il n'a pas répondu à
votre deuxième partie à notre parler
avec l'exécutif non pas encore
directement si ce n'est effectivement
dans les auditions maintenant que le
rapport est véritablement public on
espère que l'exécutif va pouvoir non
seulement en prendre connaissance dans
sa totalité mais aussi potentiellement
s'en inspirer à charge à lui de le faire
peut-être à travers un certain nombre de
véhicules législatifs à venir on a cité
directement la loi de programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie parce qu'on pense
que c'est un véhicule législatif dans
lequel une partie des propositions que
nous faisons peuvent être intégrés il y
a le projet de loi de finance 2024 qui
va arriver à l'automne là aussi très
certainement il y aura peut-être des
propositions que nous pourrons porter
par par voie d'amendement puis après on
s'interdit pas de faire un véhicule
législatif qui soit propre à cette
commission d'enquête en tant à travers
une proposition de loi
France alors j'ai quelques questions une
sur le rapport avec l'Union européenne
une autre sur le chauffage et une
dernière sur la digitalisation la
première sur l'Union européenne alors
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'il y a
une directive en cours de révision
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de cette
directive des objectifs des Caps
financiers voilà savoir un petit peu
votre sentiment là-dessus et si ça fait
part de votre travail une deuxième
question sur le débat pompe à chaleur
chaudière à gaz qui a déjà été assez
Houlé en Allemagne les écologistes ont
proposé d'aller plus loin les libéraux
et les conservateurs hors de la
coalition ont mené une forme de fronde
est-ce que vous craignez que ce soit
quelque chose qui puisse détendre sur le
débat français je vous pose la question
à tous les deux
dans le même dans le même chapeau sur le
chauffage j'ai eu récemment un article
sur le chauffage à bois et qui pose
apparemment problème est-ce que vous
avez des réactions à ce sujet là et une
dernière question pardon sur la
digitalisation
Schneider Electric par exemple propose
voilà pour les passements la demande
tout ça de digitaliser à fond le
domestique c'est à dire voilà les objets
connectés tout ça est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez pris en
compte avec des propositions dans votre
rapport merci beaucoup
oui je vais je vais commencer par la fin
du coup puisque sur la digitalisation on
a on a effectivement auditionné
notamment un représentant de Schneider
Electric et surtout cette question de à
la fois digitalisation à la fois de
défassement enfin tout cas tous les
dispositifs qui permettent de faire des
économies de dispositifs qui vont
éteindre le chauffage quand on est pas
là etc ça c'est des éléments qui sont
importants on a des propositions aussi
justement dans le dans le rapport à ce à
ce sujet là
qui sont absolument pas à négliger au
contraire qu'on est qui sont souvent
très efficaces en fait à la fois souvent
peu coûteuse et qui ont une efficacité
directe très importante après ce qu'on
dit c'est encore une fois c'est de faire
attention de ne pas dire voilà c'est la
solution miracle et on va mettre ça et
tout sera réglé parce que on a beau
avoir des systèmes d'évitement de
régulation du chauffage si on est dans
une passoire thermique si on est dans un
logement dans lequel on a des courants
d'air dans lequel on a des difficultés à
chauffer on voit bien que ça ne réglera
pas la question on aura peut-être une
petite réduction de notre consommation
donc voilà c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'il faut voir dans sa globalité et ça
fait partie des solutions qui peuvent
être apportées et qui sont plutôt
intéressants et notamment dans le
collectif je pense que dans les
copropriétés d'avoir cette réflexion
globale sur une copropriété dans le
collectif ça c'est intéressant on a
encore un certain nombre de copropriétés
ou il y a absolument pas de régulation
du chauffage on a encore des
copropriétés on sait où l'hiver les gens
voulaient fenêtres parce qu'il fait trop
chaud mais parce qu'ils peuvent pas
réguler leur leur chauffage
individuellement donc oui il y a
effectivement vraiment à progresser sur
cette sur cet aspect là sur la question
européenne donc on est allé à Bruxelles
et on a on a fait on a fait cette un
certain nombre d'auditions sur alors
effectivement au niveau européen c'est
en discussion les orientations dans
discussion ce qu'on a plutôt vu c'est
que c'était plutôt ça allait plutôt dans
le sens de ce que déjà on avait pu un
petit peu imaginer avec quand même des
objectifs qui sont en hausse avec des
objectifs encore plus ambitieux donc
c'est pour ça qu'on dit que d'autant
plus on va avoir besoin vraiment de de
s'adapter c'est ce que je disais aussi
dans le cadre du DPE on voit vraiment
que le DPE devient un élément central
alors on aura pas le même forcément le
même DPE face c'est difficile
d'harmoniser les DPE à l'échelle
européenne parce que c'est une des
questions qu'on a pu qu'on a pu poser
pour plein de raisons et parce que
chaque pays voilà mais par contre on va
avoir des seuils à atteindre qui
pourront être harmonisés par enfin sur
l'ensemble au niveau au niveau européen
donc des seuils ça veut dire qu'on
n'aura pas forcément ça correspondra pas
forcément à la même lettre dans certains
pays mais en tout cas on pourrait avoir
des c'est en tout cas c'est vers ça
qu'on s'oriente plutôt et donc c'est
pour ça aussi que dans les propositions
qu'on a pu faire on s'est évidemment
orienté dans les discussions qu'on peut
avoir et dans ce qu'on pouvait présager
pour aller justement dans cette dans
cette direction
dans les autres questions oui génial des
types de des types de chauffage encore
une fois et c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
appuie beaucoup sur le sur l'aspect
local et de s'appuyer aussi sur la
question des collectivités locales sur
d'avoir de l'ingénierie locale parce que
c'est vrai que le type de chauffage en
fonction de là où on peut être va
dépendre si on a un réseau de chaleur
évidemment c'est mieux et c'est toujours
mieux de se mettre et de se raccorder un
réseau de chaleur et je dirais quel que
soit le type de production de chaleur
même si c'est une production qui n'est
pas bonne on sait qu'on pourra de toute
façon la modifier la remplacer mais en
tout cas voilà on sera sur du sur deux
collectif et on voit encore aujourd'hui
liés justement à ce système d'aide même
dans des copropriétés où on va remplacer
et mettre des pompes à chaleur
individuels alors qu'on avait un réseau
de chaleur qui passe très pas loin donc
je pense qu'il faut avoir ce
raisonnement là sur la question sur la
question du chauffage au bois il y a eu
un certain le nombre d'études et encore
une fois avec avec des choses localement
qui sont qui ont été faites de manière
assez précise moi je vois sur mon sur
mon territoire en Isère c'est vrai que
l'impact notamment du chauffage bois
cancer du chauffage foyers ouverts ou
peu adapté qui
il y a un impact effectivement sur la
pollution de l'air qui est très
importante donc ça c'est des choses et
là ça rentre aussi dans le cadre de
l'azde aussi des aides et des primes sur
le changement du type de chauffage on
peut rester sur le bois mais avec des
systèmes de chauffage qui soit justement
beaucoup plus à la fois plus performant
et moins émissif en tout cas sur sur la
fois sur les particules et sur la et sur
la pollution de l'air mais on a aussi
des réseaux de des réseaux de chaleur
avec avec du bois qui sont plutôt aussi
intéressants donc en fait c'est c'est
vraiment d'avoir un raisonnement sur un
mix énergétique et de ne pas aller je
dirais de manière un peu simpliste sur
un type un type de chauffage mais de
vraiment s'adapter c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a remis au coeur la question de la
géothermie parce que c'est vrai que
c'est aussi des éléments qui peuvent
être particulièrement intéressants on a
d'ailleurs appris que le bâtiment dans
lequel on est entièrement chauffé avec
de la géothermie depuis je crois deux
ans deux ou trois ans donc voilà c'est
aussi des aspects sur lequel il faut il
faut il faut essayer de réfléchir et moi
je crois vraiment justement à cette
expertise locale sur ces questions là
le rapporteur l'a dit on a voulu montrer
aussi que cette politique de rénovation
énergétique des logements elle avait
bien deux piliers c'était bien la
décarbonation à travers le changement
des systèmes de chauffage mais ce
n'était pas que ça bien évidemment il y
avait tout ce qui touchait à la fois à
la sobriété énergétique et à la
rénovation profonde et réelle des
logements et quand vous parliez des
nouvelles technologies en particulier
tout ce qui touche à des bâtiments
connectés ça rentre pleinement dans une
politique de sobriété énergétique mais
là aussi ça rejoint le dernier point qui
a évoqué devant vous le rapporteur ça
fait partie aujourd'hui de cette
nécessité de former un certain nombre de
professionnels et dans tes
professionnels qu'il nous faut former
c'est toute la chaîne qui doit être
concernée aussi bien de l'ouvrier
jusqu'à l'architecte mais aussi jusqu'à
des professionnels qui s'approprient ces
nouvelles technologies pour pouvoir
ensuite effectivement faire en sorte que
ces bâtiments puissent devenir connecté
et puisse apporter des réponses en
matière de de sobriété énergétique il
s'agissant des chaudières à gaz je pense
que bon là il y a une consultation qui a
été lancée par le gouvernement on va
voir ce que ça donne mais on nous a dit
aussi dans les auditions donc on est
effectivement dire une interdiction des
chaudière à gaz rapide immédiate tout de
suite dit 26 c'est véritablement signe
que ça peut amener encore comme on a
connu au moment des gilets jaunes un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens à dire
mais on y arrivera pas et puis toute
façon on nous a soit encouragé à mettre
des chaudières à gaz maintenant il faut
plus en mettre et on nous a dit aussi
que dans certains endroits il n'était
pas possible de changer les chaudières à
gaz certes on peut peut-être trouver des
chaudière à gaz qui soient plus
performantes mais il y a des endroits où
techniquement ce n'est pas possible que
de dire on interdit purement et
simplement la chaudière à gaz
oui
oui vous pouvez
du coup j'ai pas entendu le nom mais
si vous pouvez poser votre question vous
écoute oui bonjour vous avez parlé
beaucoup du DPE qui avait une place
centrale dans cette fameuse rénovation
énergétique vous voulez le rendre plus
robuste plus de sécurité autour de ça
vous avez parlé beaucoup de la filière
du bâtiment et très peu de la filière de
la profession du diagnostic immobilier
est-ce qu'il est question d'une carte
professionnelle est-ce qui va être
question de restructurer ce métier de
revoir justement cette formation parce
que vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
beaucoup d'abus autour de tout ça donc
je voulais savoir si la Commission avait
travaillé sur cette question et quels
étaient les résultats
oui complètement ce sujet nous a pas
nous a pas échappé sur ce que je disais
sur la sur la question du DPE
[Musique]
comme il est central bah oui il faut
qu'il soit le plus incontestable
possible et donc il faut effectivement
que la question des diagnostiqueurs ça
soit oui à la fois un vrai métier
d'aller vers une vraie
professionnalisation de ces
diagnostiqueurs et effectivement on
propose de créer une carte une carte
professionnelle et également d'avoir
aussi des contrôles beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus réguliers sur sur
l'ensemble de ces de ces diagnostics qui
peuvent être qui peuvent être faits
parce que oui ils sont ils sont
importants et c'est vrai que on a rendu
le DPE opposable donc il faut que voilà
quand on quand on propose de plus
pouvoir louer un louer un logement parce
que il est classé en g par exemple il
faut que ça correspond à quelque chose
et puis surtout que ça correspondent
aussi à quelque chose quand on fait les
travaux et qu'on fasse évoluer justement
ce bâtiment donc il y a cette nécessité
justement de faire de professionnaliser
et puis évidemment d'avoir tout un
aspect de contrôle sur ces sur ces
diagnostiqueurs
c'est vrai qu'on a vu que pour l'instant
c'était pas encore totalement le cas en
tout cas qui avait vraiment nécessité à
la fois en termes de formation et puis
c'est vrai que on va avoir besoin de
plus en plus de diagnostiqueurs donc il
faut vraiment qu'on ait un système de
formation et de contrôle important pour
que on puisse voilà qu'on puisse avoir
total totalement confiance dans cette
dans cet outil
il y avait Christine le joue
oui bonjour vous m'entendez
oui bonjour Merci beaucoup excusez-moi
je pense que ma question va être un
petit peu redondante avec la précédente
mais je n'ai pas complètement entendu
tout à l'heure vous avez dit justement
que le DPE il fallait le rendre beaucoup
plus fiable beaucoup plus robuste or le
ministre du Logement assure depuis
plusieurs mois que depuis le nouveau
nouveau DPE de l'automne 2021 il est
fiable que là où il y a un problème
c'est dans comment dire
l'homogénéité pardon de sa réalisation
par les diagnostiqueurs du coup est-ce
que vous partagez cet avis ou est-ce que
vous c'est plutôt il faut encore
soulever le capot du DPE pour aller
regarder dans le moteur s'il vous plaît
en tout cas c'est sûr que entre la phase
1 du DPE et puis la nouvelle phase il y
a eu des progrès on a on a un outil qui
devient en tout cas en tout cas
intéressant on a encore puisque on a on
a tous eu des retours avec des
diagnostics qu'on peut être fait sur un
même bâtiment avec des résultats qui
peuvent être souvent souvent différents
alors là derrière il y a aussi souvent
plusieurs problématiques puisque c'est
vrai que un diagnostiqueur il va faire
son diagnostic en fonction des éléments
qui lui sont fournis et des éléments qui
peut avoir donc c'est vrai que entre et
c'est ce qui se peut se passer aussi
souvent c'est que des gens qui font leur
diagnostic pour louer leur logement
souvent sans préoccupe pas trop le
diagnostiqué revient il a très peu
d'éléments sur la qualité des
menuiseries la facture etc sur le type
d'isolation qui a été mis dans les
combles enfin j'en passe
et puis ben on arrive à un résultat qui
est qui peut ne pas être très
satisfaisant et là en général la
personne se dit ah bah oui tiens faut
peut-être quand même que je regarde et
en donnant en fait l'ensemble de ces
éléments on arrive effectivement à un
résultat qui peut être différent donc il
y a cet aspect là et donc ça ça passe
par un aspect en termes de de
communication d'explication en fait de
l'après de ceux qui vont faire un DPE
pour se dire il y a une la base
effectivement de récolter l'ensemble des
éléments du maximum d'éléments qu'on
peut avoir il y a des possibilités aussi
puisque moi j'ai fait le test puisque
j'ai fait faire un TPE
chez moi pour voir en fait et pour
suivre directement et voir comment ça se
passait c'est sûr que ça demande aussi
une vraie professionnalisation puisque
on peut demander à ce que des tests
puissent être fait avec des petites
caméras pour voir exactement ce qui peut
se trouver dans les murs dans les
combles etc donc on peut pousser en tout
cas le diagnostiqueur elle est assez
loin dans ce qui peut être fait
maintenant il faut que ça soit beaucoup
plus harmonisé et puis on a détecté un
certain nombre nous de d'éléments en
tout cas soit qu'il fallait intégrer
j'ai parlé du confort thermique d'été
c'est des éléments qu'il faut qu'on
puisse intégrer dans le dans le DPE on a
parlé du bâti du bâti existant et de la
prise en compte de ce bâti existant et
également des matériaux biosourcés
puisque c'est matériaux biosourcés et
l'effet en fait c'est matériaux sourcés
notamment sur le confort d'été sont pas
pris en compte suffisamment dans le dans
le DPE donc là on a aussi des
propositions pour prendre en compte de
de meilleure manière c'est ces matériaux
là dans le dans le DPE donc on fait
c'est on fait ces propositions pour
avancer on a aussi des effets de seuil
parfois qui sont trop importants et donc
qu'on a aucune signaler par exemple sur
l'altitude si vous avez un bâtiment qui
est à 800 1 m bah vous pouvez passer de
catégorie entre 800 1 et ici il est à
799 mètres ce qui est pas anodin quoi
c'est à dire qu'on peut passer d'un
logement qui ne soit plus qu'il ne soit
plus louable ou louable à 3 mètres
d'altitude de différence donc on voit
qu'on a besoin aussi de lisser en fait
en tout cas de gommer ses effets de
seuil donc voilà il y a un certain
nombre d'éléments qui sont encore à
faire progresser
mais ça passait loin d'être à
surmontable et puis en ayant aussi
auditionné les diagnostiqueurs on voit
que c'est tout à fait possible
pas tout à fait possible de les intégrer
et moi je suis persuadé qu'on peut
arriver en tout cas un dispositif qui
soit sur lequel on puisse se baser en
tout cas et qui a en plus un rôle assez
pédagogique quoi c'est-à-dire que le
fait de savoir que on a un bâtiment qui
est classé de telle manière on peut le
faire évoluer et qu'on nous dit en plus
et qu'on nous explique comment le faire
évoluer je trouve que c'est plus
important et c'est pour ça aussi que ce
DPE nous l'associe au carnet de santé du
bâtiment au passeport du bâtiment donc
il va être qui est mis en place avec qui
était dans le cadre de la loi climat et
résilience mais du coup de se dire que
chaque bâtiment devra avoir en fait un
passeport avec justement le DPE et ce
passeport qui suivra en fonction des
propriétaires et qui permettra de
poursuivre ce parcours de rénovation
merci beaucoup
filière des diagnostiqueurs on a
auditionné bien sûr un ensemble des
défédérations nationales de
diagnostiqueur donc ils ont bien
conscience aujourd'hui que leur
profession est une profession qui a
besoin d'une formation renforcée qu'elle
soit continue ou initiales et qu'elle a
besoin d'une professionnalisation qui va
au-delà aujourd'hui de la simple
certification de l'agrément qui est
donné c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
faisons la proposition que puisse être
attribué au diagnostiqueur une carte
professionnelle bien évidemment sous
réserve de contrôle qui soit réalisé et
donc c'est même fédérations nationales
de diagnostiqueurs nous ont dit aussi
que c'était un métier aujourd'hui qui
était un métier de reconversion pour
leur dire qui a pratiquement 80% des
diagnostiqueurs qui décident de devenir
diagnostiquaire en cours de leur
carrière et donc ça ça montre aussi le
besoin qu'il y a de cette formation
quand une personne décide de se
reconvertir pour embrasser ce métier qui
va forcément être de plus en plus
important donc je crois que là tout le
monde en a bien conscience bien sûr je
sais que le ministre du Logement les a
réunis a annoncé que des propositions
seraient faites dans le courant de l'été
au mois d'août mais nous nous
informerons déjà un certain nombre et je
sais que aussi les fédérations
nationales des diagnostiqueurs ont bien
conscience aujourd'hui qu'il faut que
ils améliorent parce qu'il y a des
écarts de DPE entre diagnostiqueurs pour
un même logement qui peuvent être
extrêmement
énorme de d'un DPE à un autre et qui
cause et qui a des conséquences non des
moindres sur ensuite le parcours de
rénovation énergétique des logements
merci alors oui nous avons constaté
aussi que le DPE prenait mal en compte
les spécificités du bâti ancien le bâti
patrimonial d'avant 1810
et en fait nous avons demandé une des
préconisations que nous avons faites et
de revenir enfin de créer un DPE qui
aurait qui prendrait mieux en compte ces
spécificités donc un DPE patrimonial et
en attendant en fait qu'il soit qu'ils
puissent être mis en oeuvre si possible
avant les premières interdictions de
location en 2025 de revenir sur un
calcul du DPE sur facture qui prendrait
mieux en compte en fait les usages
particuliers et les matériaux
spécifiques à ce type de bâti en fait
nous avons constaté que pour le premier
trimestre 2023 60% du bâti d'avant 1948
a été classé F ou G
donc ça ça peut s'avérer vraiment
problématique et même accentuer la crise
du logement puisqu'à terme on sait que
c'est logement ne pourront plus être
loués et un logement de ce type qui
n'est plus loué va se dégrader très vite
et condamné à plus ou moins long terme
une question de Claire année
oui claire année c'est à vous
sur le DPE collectif pour les
copropriétés vous proposez que si ce DPE
collectif est bon il supplante le DPE
individuel donc cela rendrait louable
les pires passoires thermiques dansaient
déjà interdite à la location point
d'interrogation deuxième question
proposez-vous aussi une évolution des
DPE pour les petites surfaces pour
l'instant plus à risque d'être mal
classé
alors juste la dernière la fin c'était
proposez-vous aussi une évolution des
DPE pour les petites surfaces pour
l'instant plus à risque d'être mal
classé
le monde
sur le sur le DPE sur le DPE collectif
donc on propose effectivement de de
passer d'un DPE cholécrin de rendre
opposable des PE le DPE collectif plutôt
que le DPE individuel ça veut pas dire
que en passant des PE collectif on va au
contraire permettre que des passoires
thermiques puissent être soit pas rénové
et puisse être puisse être mis à la
location
un c'est que si on a un bâtiment
collectif
qui n'est pas isolé sur lequel il y a eu
aucun travaux de réaliser il aura de
toute façon une note qui risque d'être
très négative en tout cas plutôt proche
de de FG et donc au contraire d'avoir
plutôt l'ensemble des logements qui sont
dans cette copropriété d'avoir cette
nécessité de ce de se mettre en
conformité en tout cas de travailler sur
cette rénovation thermique et justement
plutôt de dire globalement
collectivement il y a cette nécessité de
pouvoir y aller après par contre c'est
vrai que ça permet quand même d'éviter
des effets où on sait qu'on peut avoir
des logements qui sont très défavorisés
sur certaines copropriétés ça peut être
des logements par exemple du dernier
étage sur lequel il y a il y a pas eu où
il y a des difficultés de faire
l'isolation en toiture et donc du coup
il y a des difficultés puisque ça va
concerner quelques logements par exemple
du dernier niveau et les autres
logements qui sont en dessous ne vont
pas enfin vont être elles vont être
classés plutôt favorablement on voit
bien que la prise de décision va être
très compliquée et donc là ça permet
d'avoir cet aspect cet aspect collectif
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'on enlève le
DPE pour les logements pour les
logements individuels mais il sera plus
opposable mais ça permettra quand même
aussi de dire que s'il reste un logement
qui est classé g dans l'ensemble d'une
copropriété qui elle serait classée que
c'est pas d on a quand même l'indication
et notamment sur la location on sait que
ça va dévaloriser effectivement ce
logement puisque ben on sait que les le
coût et le coût énergétique et le coût
des dépenses énergétiques sera beaucoup
plus sera beaucoup plus élevé mais le
but ici on regarde globalement en
faisant un DPE collectif en général
c'est pas forcément favorable en fait
donc c'est c'est plutôt et je trouve
c'est plutôt logique en fait et de
favoriser justement l'isolation de
l'enveloppe du bâtiment et pour pas
plutôt avoir des des rénovations qui
soient individuelles et souvent qui vont
à même à l'encontre de ce qu'il faudrait
faire en fait collectivement quoi
et puis
donc mais peut-être sur les sur les
petites surfaces ça fait partie
effectivement de ce que l'on préconise
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont revoir le mode
de calcul du DPE ça concerne
principalement le biais aujourd'hui
effectivement des petites surfaces ça
concerne le bâti ancien dans sa Bible
dragster vous a pas parce que le bâti
ancien aujourd'hui est complètement un
impensé de la politique de rénovation
énergétique des logements et ça concerne
aussi sur ce mode de calcul du DPE ce
que vous êtes ce dont vous a parlé de
rapporteur c'est à dire le confort d'été
dont nous préconisons qu'il soit
vraiment intégré à la note enfin sur les
copropriétés ce qu'on peut constater
aujourd'hui c'est que ma prime rénov
copropriété ne marche pas bien ou en
tout cas n'est pas à la hauteur du défi
qu'il y a à relever en matière de
copropriété qu'il faudra rénover et
aujourd'hui bien évidemment il y a un
tas de règles qui sont de nature à être
plutôt des freins par rapport à
s'embarquer dans une rénovation
énergétique d'une copropriété parce je
sais que tous les copropriétaires ne
sont pas si j'ose dire loger à la même
enseigne qui ne sont pas tous solidaires
et qu'à travers un DPE collectif et bien
on rend aussi solidaire et qu'à partir
de ce moment-là aussi on peut dans un
deuxième temps assouplir certaines
règles qui régissent le droit de
copropriété passer par exemple après à
des décisions qui peuvent être prises à
la majorité simple parce que l'un des
défis quand même la maison individuelle
c'est une chose il y en a beaucoup à
rénover mais dans un certain nombre de
nos grandes villes le défi sur la
rénovation énergétique des logements
c'est celui des copropriétés qui va
véritablement se poser
il y a un autre intérêt aussi sur le DPE
collectif c'est que ça permet d'avoir
une vraie visibilité aussi sur
l'ensemble des copropriétés puisque du
coup on va avancer sur ces sur
l'ensemble de ces DPE collectifs ça
permettra de voir réellement
où on est chaque propriété copropriété
et d'avoir aussi une démarche d'aller
vers c'est ce qu'on a pu voir d'ailleurs
sur
Annie station comité urbaine de Nice qui
peut être aussi intéressant puisque des
collectivités en lien avec les agences
locales de l'énergie de pouvoir vraiment
se dire bah voilà on a un certain nombre
de collectifs de copropriétés sur lequel
on a oui soit des passoires thermiques
en tout cas qui ont des résultats qui
sont très très mauvais et donc de
pouvoir aller vers expliquer les
démarches pour pour aller vers cette
rénovation mettre en place tout
l'accompagnement qui peuvent qui peut se
qui peut se faire et donc c'est aussi
une manière d'avoir cette cette
visibilité cette connaissance en fait du
du parc bâti
dernière question en salle et ensuite de
deux questions en ligne bonjour les
empirer pour la Gifi actif trois petites
questions en fait la première c'est par
rapport les deux premières sont par
rapport à l'exécutif est-ce que Olivier
Klein était auditionné l'enquête de
votre commission qu'est ce que l'on a
ressorti ensuite comment votre travail
s'inscrit dans le scénario logement en
fait qui s'est présenté à quelques
semaines est-ce que vous avez participé
est-ce que vous avez été consulté ou pas
et sur la suite au rapport alors c'est
un peu retournant à ce que vous avec ce
que vous disiez la scène triste tout à
l'heure j'ai bien compris vous pourriez
intégrer certaines des propositions à
différents véhicules législatifs mais
est-ce qu'il est prévu une présentation
ne sera pas exécutif de manière
automatique au-delà de ce que de la
tension que pourrait donner l'exécutif à
l'inverse à votre rapport
alors sur sur Olivier Klein évidemment
il a été auditionné je crois que même
c'est le dernier qui était auditionné
puisqu'on a fini par les ministres qui
sont qui sont en poste donc son audition
est visible dans le dans le dans le
rapport
sur son sur son audition parce que je
pourrais dire c'est que il y a
il y a enfin je trouve qu'il y avait une
peut-être une difficulté à vraiment voir
une auto-satisfaction on va dire des
choses qui sont mises en place
et de se dire bah voilà on est on est
sur un parcours ce qu'on est en ce qu'on
met en place
effectivement peut commencer à prendre
de la cohérence va fonctionner et en
gros ben il ne faut rien changer il faut
qu'on continue comme ça et un petit peu
tout ira bien nous on dit on a des
éléments qui sont intéressants
maintenant il faut redonner à la fois de
la cohérence il faut aussi aller plus
vite et c'est pour ça qu'on propose
aussi des des montants et notamment sur
la question du logement social et qui
concerne d'ailleurs directement
Olivier Klein pour lui dire là on a
vraiment les moyens de pouvoir aller
très vite de pouvoir donner les moyens
de réaliser justement l'ensemble de ces
travaux et d'avoir un impact très fort
donc allons-y quoi et comme ça a été dit
en plus le fait de cet argent qu'on met
c'est pas l'argent à fond perdu c'est de
l'argent qui est retourne sur les sur
les territoires qui met en place des
filières donc là c'est vrai que j'avoue
qu'on n'a pas eu de réponse très très
clair sur sur ces propositions en tout
cas pour pour pouvoir bosser notamment
sur le sur le logement social après sur
alors le CNR c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
forcément enfin on a vu un petit peu les
propositions plutôt l'absence
proposition liée liée au CNR
moi je pense que l'objectif en tout cas
du rapport c'est justement nous on s'est
ciblé vraiment sur cette question de la
rénovation thermique et de la rénovation
thermique des logements on a fait ses
propositions là évidemment qu'après
voilà là on est sur le rendu du rapport
on a voté le rapport maintenant il
existe il est là on a cette cet outil
maintenant il va falloir faire vivre
donc il va y avoir effectivement le lien
avec les différents ministères et voilà
moi effectivement d'avoir à la fois une
présentation et en tout cas d'une portée
à connaissance à l'ensemble des
ministères des propositions qu'on peut
faire et puis des rencontres pour voir
effectivement quels sont les
propositions qui pourraient être
retenues et puis après on a tout le
cadre législatif ça a été dit on va
avoir la loi de finances on va voir la
loi de programmation de l'énergie sur
lequel on va pouvoir venir insérer
justement un certain nombre de
propositions forcément aussi en
discussion avec avec le gouvernement
mais je pense que voilà donc tout ce
qu'on a pu balayer je pense que c'est un
outil plutôt et d'ailleurs c'est comme
ça que j'avais pris l'ensemble l'ont
pris l'ensemble des ministres et Olivier
Klein en disant ça va leur servir et
c'est un outil qui peut être plutôt
intéressant pour faire évoluer les
politiques publiques donc c'est vraiment
le but de ce de ce rapport c'est sûr que
si le rapport dès ce soir on le range
dans un placard et puis que et puis qui
sert plus à rien voilà il aura pas eu
voilà on aura appris beaucoup de choses
mais en tout cas donc là ce qu'on ce
qu'on souhaite c'est qu'au contraire il
poursuivre sa vie ensuite on a aussi la
possibilité via des propositions de loi
etc de reprendre aussi un des éléments
donc ça pour l'instant c'est peut-être
encore un peu tôt pour le dire je pense
qu'on a des biais législatifs en tout
cas pour vraiment faire nos propositions
et puis faire en sorte de les voilà les
pousser
Fanny Guibert pour 60 millions de
consommateurs avez-vous des propositions
sur l'audit énergétique pourquoi ne pas
imposer un audit et supprimer le DPE
alors
pourquoi ne pas
en fait en tout cas il y a des on a des
propositions en termes de peut-être de
simplification c'est à dire que entre
DPE
audit énergétique en c'est le la vente
d'une maison c'est vrai qu'il y a une
lisibilité qui est un peu complexe
l'intérêt de l'audit c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus précis qui va beaucoup
plus loin qui permet d'aller jusqu'à un
chiffrage de travaux qu'il faudrait
réaliser de véritables déperditions
énergétiques donc oui c'est un outil qui
serait le je dirais le plus performant
possible son inconvénient quand même
c'est qu'il a un coût qui est plus
important
et donc on peut difficilement
généraliser l'autre aspect c'est que je
l'ai dit le DPE et maintenant qu'on le
veuille ou pas c'est devenu un élément
central et au niveau européen donc c'est
un peu ça serait un peu difficile toute
façon de sortir de cet outil donc on a
préféré plutôt dire rendons ce DPE là
beaucoup plus performants faisant un
outil plutôt voilà efficace qui permet
quand même moi je trouve qu'il a quand
même des éléments qui sont vraiment
intéressants pour placer une trajectoire
de rénovation de rénovation énergétique
dans une dans une vraie dans une vraie
logique de performance et puis après
effectivement mais toute façon l'audit
il le sera pour l'ensemble des
copropriétés dès qu'on est dans le
collectif donc voilà mais je pense que
pour l'individuel je pense déjà le fait
puisque ce qu'on regarde sur ma prime
rénov 700 000 gestes si on regarde sur
les chaussettes 100000 gestes si c'est
70 ou 72 % je crois de changement de
chaudière pour ces 72% la plupart du
temps il n'y a eu aucune étude c'est à
dire qu'on est allé directement
chez choix soit chez l'entreprise
directement soit via des sites internet
on a changé la chaudière il y a eu
aucune étude globale nous on propose au
moins maintenant qui est à minima
justement ce DPE qui permet de d'avoir
une vis ibilité là le l'audit serait
meilleur mais c'est vrai que c'est pour
le coup un peu plus compliqué et un peu
plus plus coûteux
ils ont toujours de Fanny Guibert pour
60 millions de consommateurs que
proposez-vous précisément pour les
chaudières à gaz
alors on en a un petit peu parlé tout à
l'heure
sur les sur les chaudières à gaz nous on
propose tout simplement c'est un de pas
aller trop vite en fait dans la dans la
réduction en tout cas de ces chaudières
et surtout de ne pas les interdire
en tout cas immédiatement
parce que un on a encore besoin de ce
type de chauffage et que le gaz reste
quand même une énergie de transition
qu'on a des dispositifs que ça soit sur
sur l'utilisation de de la biomasse et
donc de du gaz du gaz vert donc voilà il
faut qu'on puisse encore avoir des
outils puisqu'on a des unités de
méthanisation dans certains territoires
même si c'est une toute petite partie ça
serait dommage que du coup on puisse pas
se chauffer avec ce gaz qui est produit
donc on dit qu'il faut voilà avoir
encore une fois cette vision plutôt
plutôt locale intégré dans un mixte dans
un mix énergétique après c'est sûr que
il faut qu'on décarbonne donc il faut
qu'on privilégie plutôt votre type
d'énergie et surtout qu'on privilégie la
rénovation la rénovation globale et donc
la sobriété pour limiter justement les
déperditions c'est évidemment cette
priorité là mais on se dit que la
chaudière gaz peut avoir des intérêts ça
peut avoir des intérêts aussi en
complément avec les pompes à chaleur
dans les territoires plutôt de montagne
ou d'altitude on sait que les pompes à
chaleur ont des rendements qui sont très
très faibles et donc couplé avec des
chaudières gaz et des choses qui peuvent
qui peuvent fonctionner donc voilà nous
on dit tout simplement que il faut
plutôt être prudent sur sur ces
interdictions ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut les favoriser et donc il faut les
subventionner mais en tout cas de
laisser la possibilité dans certains cas
quand c'est voilà quand ça a du sens oui
il faut il faut pouvoir le permettre
question de Rachida bouh grillé pour
actu environnement les 300 millions
d'euros à louer à partir de 2024 grâce
au CE pour financer les prestations des
accompagnateurs rénovs sont-ils
suffisants et cuites de la contribution
des collectivités
alors en fait c'est toute une série de
questions sur lequel on n'a pas eu
spécifiquement de réponse encore puisque
sur mon accompagnateur rénove à la fois
c'est ce que je disais de tout à l'heure
le
dans le la précision de ce qu'est
l'accompagnateur rénove et qu'elle va
être réellement sa mission globale c'est
vrai que la ministre nous a répondu
plutôt que ça allait être une mission
assez complète d'une accompagnement
assez assez forte quasi jusque pas de la
maîtrise d'oeuvre mais en tout cas qui
s'en qui s'en rapproche et donc avec une
prestation qui peut coûter jusqu'à 1500
2000 euros en tout cas c'était ce qui a
pu être annoncé on attend d'avoir un
petit peu des précisions là-dessus pour
l'instant c'est ce que la ministre a
annoncé donc c'est vrai que ça va poser
la question de la prise en charge de cet
accompagnateur nous ce qu'on dit c'est
qu'il faut absolument que cette
incomérateur toute façon sa prise en
charge soit totale pour en tout cas les
modestes les foyers les plus modestes ça
c'est c'est une évidence après si on
fait le calcul sur les 300 justement
les 300 millions qui sont affectés ça va
dépendre effectivement de la prestation
parce que c'est pas la même chose si
c'est une prestation à 200-300 euros ou
si c'est une prestation à 1000 ou 1500
euros donc il faudra voir effectivement
la cohérence entre les budgets qui sont
affectés et la prise en charge justement
de ce de cet accompagnateur Renov encore
une fois nous on pense que
l'accompagnateur est neuve il est
important il est intéressant dans
l'ensemble du dans l'ensemble du
parcours mais à condition aussi que on
est justement cet élément de confiance
encore une fois qu'on va avoir on va
dire un nouveau métier donc il y a
encore une question aussi de de
formation de contrôle de ce métier là
qui est aussi important parce que si on
n'arrive pas à voir cet élément de
confiance je dirais qu'on a on aura on
aura perdu en tout cas sur sur ce rôle
primordial que peut avoir
l'accompagnateur rénove
donc il va se mettre en place après du à
partir du 1er septembre c'est vrai que
on n'est pas contre la mission pour
l'instant le rapporteur l'a dit elle
demeure floue est-ce que c'est de
l'assistance administrative est-ce que
c'est du Conseil est-ce que c'est
véritablement la maîtrise d'oeuvre qui
prendrait l'intégralité de de la chaîne
et ce que j'avais déjà soulevé dans la
loi climat et résilience j'avais déjà
alerté sur la nécessité de la neutralité
et de l'indépendance de mon
accompagnement acteur et neuf et surtout
de pas opposer mon accompagnateur rénov
avec aujourd'hui les les agences qui
sont sur place dans les territoires Ajax
d'information et d'accompagnement qui
pour nous doivent continuer à être le
lieu ressource la porte d'entrée parce
que d'abord bon nombre de nos
concitoyens ils ont complètement
identifié sur le territoire parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des donc des
dispositifs qui marchent très très bien
d'un territoire à un autre et donc ça
serait dommageable que ça puisse plus et
il faudra qu'il y ait cette cohérence et
cette coordination entre accompagnateur
rénov et les structures existantes déjà
sur le territoire qui doivent continuer
à jouer ce rôle central pour ensuite
embarquer nos concitoyens dans un
parcours de d'accompagnement et de
rénovation et puis aussi on sera
vigilant qu'il y ait pas des risques de
fraude ou des faits pervers ou de Ben à
travers un accompagnateur rénov qui
pourrait voilà être alors je dis c'est
peut-être mot pour être en accord avec
ensuite l'entreprise qui irait contrôler
les travaux donc il faudra quand même
être vigilant aussi sur cet aspect de
neutralité
[Musique]
alors vous m'entendez oui très bien
donc on a beaucoup parlé les deux rôles
central du besoin de l'adapter on sait
que pour l'adapter il y a des délais de
mise en oeuvre la dernière fois il a
fallu deux ans à peu près pour réformer
ma question est toute simple est-ce que
ça se télescope pas avec le calendrier
de climat et résilience et de façon
pragmatique est-ce que vous avez pas
aussi des recommandations pour peut-être
alors non pas décalé mais prévoir des
dérogations à ce calendrier pour éviter
justement une sortie massive de passoire
énergétique
de une atrophie de l'offre locative par
exemple
alors sur le sur le DPE c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas on n'est pas sur une réforme
du DPE on a un certain nombre de on a
dès que tu étais détecté un certain
nombre de d'éléments qui pourraient
venir conforter donner un peu plus de
robustesse au DPE et je pense pas que ça
demande un temps exceptionnel enfin en
tout cas pensez nécessite de cibler un
peu quelques quelques éléments
ce qu'on dit aussi sur la formation etc
oui ça c'est quelque chose qui peut
prendre tu peux prendre du temps mais on
peut dire quand même qu'on a un outil le
DPE avec sa nouvelle formule qui pour
moi reste quand même un élément plutôt
intéressant et qui permet quand même
parce que même si on peut toujours
discuter entre j'ai ouf entre telle ou
tel diagnostiqueur on est quand même
face à permet quand même d'avoir une
visibilité sur là où on est le bâtiment
et là où il faut il faudrait il faudrait
aller donc je pense que on n'est pas
pour pour comment dire mais mettre un
temps d'arrêt en tout cas sur sur cette
sur la rénovation sur la rénovation
thermique les exonérations en fait ce
qu'on a plutôt proposé c'est notamment
avec le avec le DPE collectif sur les
sur les copropriétés de permettre
justement de répondre à ces
problématiques là qui pouvaient y avoir
pour certains logements sur la question
des des logements de petite surface
aussi de pouvoir intégrer ça je pense
que c'est des choses qui peuvent venir
justement ce s'intégrer plutôt assez
assez rapidement et qui est
effectivement lèveront un certain nombre
de de dérogations en tout cas
d'impossibilité qui pourrait y avoir sur
certains sur certains logements sachant
quand même qu'il existe déjà dans le
cadre de la loi des dérogations
possibles donc on n'est pas totalement
voilà alors on sait que c'est le TPE
voilà reste à une certaine imperfection
qui va évoluer dans le temps mais je
pense qu'il faut surtout pas qu'on
ralentisse la trajectoire bien au
contraire
vous la rappelez sur le bâti ancien là
effectivement on propose de moratoire
jusqu'en 2025 de 2 ans pour justement
parce qu'aujourd'hui rien n'est prévu à
travers le DPE sur cette cette question
du bâti ancien et donc revenir comme
Sabine l'a indiqué à l'ancien DPE avec
un contrôle sur facture
et enfin une dernière question
d'AEF Christine Lejeau qui va prendre la
parole oui Christine le joue
Christine le jour voulait poser une
question